Okay.
Here we are Super Training Gym,
Mark Smelly Bell and we are going to take a little tour showing them around the
place,
show them around the gym.
Thanks for having us.
This is one of my favorite gems.
I am excited to look at all the toys that you have here.
Also,
first off,
what on earth are these things?
Yeah.
This guy right here is called the triad.
Everything we have in the gym is a unique,
everything we have in the gym is a little different.
Uh,
we like to use thick fat handles on stuff to increase.
Our grip is a power lifting gym and we need to have a good strong grip.
So this guy here has got different grips on it.
You can do overhead work with it.
You can even just do a farmer's walk with it,
just walk with it and it's going to really test your grip a lot.
The bringing up here,
you kind of overhead press it was kind of Nice about it is with the weight
distribution being back in here,
it's kind of a little bit like a kettle bell.
It's pushing the elbow inward a little bit.
And as you press it up,
you've got to kind of press it up the same way you would press a kettle bell,
the waves just to distribute it a little differently.
So this gives you that much variance.
Everything we have and here's just a little bit different and yeah,
of course,
probably not going to see this and her local curves,
gym dumbbells up to one 50.
And what some add this.
This is also something I haven't really seen before.
And yet you have a few of these around the gym.
What is the purpose of this?
Uh,
just to,
uh,
create kind of an unstable surface.
Uh,
whenever you have some instability it's going to fire some different muscles.
And so we,
uh,
use stuff like this,
we also use a bamboo bar where we'll hook some bands around the bark and kind of
show you that too,
but it will create some instability and it's making all the little muscles fire.
And,
uh,
if we continue our tour here,
you have the old school hammer strength and use that for some of the
bodybuilding,
right?
It's of course,
I remember going to a,
what was the name of the gym?
I think it was strong island.
Jim with Kenny licenser when back in the day he had hammer strength machines
everywhere.
All purple.
That's a long story.
It was great.
Yeah.
Why?
Uh,
of course you have slingshots,
you have a lot of slingshots slingshots and he shares.
Can you show how that fits on the human body?
I can if I have one large enough for myself here.
Oh yeah.
This one will work.
So sling shot my product that I invented years ago.
It's got two patents on it.
It's a supportive upper body devices.
Very simple.
You just slide it up over your arms,
feels like,
does it fit your arms like Garrett,
but mine.
Slide it up over the arms and then once you're in there,
you're ready for some pushups.
Bench press dips.
So the slingshot actually kind of works as what I like to call double muscle.
And what I mean by that is,
as the product begins to stretch and lengthen,
so are your muscles,
your muscles are stretching and laughing as you're bringing the weights down.
When you're in the east centric portion,
the lift,
as you move on to the concentric portion of the lift,
you're getting some of the elastic properties of the slingshot is helping guide
your muscles back into kind of a contracted position as you head back towards
the top,
helps take pressure off your shoulders,
how take pressure off your elbows allows you to handle more weight for more reps
and sets in your workout.
And what are just as context,
what are some of your,
what are your best competition lifts in powerlifting?
So,
uh,
years ago I competed in,
in um,
geared powerlifting wearing,
you know,
squat suits and stuff like that and a bench shirts.
I did 854 pound bench press,
380 squat and a 766 pound deadlift.
And here at the gym,
obviously you have everything you would need for bench press,
everything you need for deadlifts,
everything you need for squat.
Uh,
the training split I guess is very similar to a different west side.
Who says some of it,
some of it is a little bit west,
west side ish in the fact that we like to change things up quite a bit here.
Um,
but we also follow a little bit of a periodization principle as well.
We're,
we'll just simply use a little bit more weight from one week to the next.
And uh,
but you have one primary,
uh,
what,
what is,
what is your,
your current schedule look like on a weekly basis in terms of primary lift and
on a weekly basis,
we have Tuesday,
Thursday,
Saturday are kind of the main training days,
Sundays,
like an assistance day,
basically getting in whatever it is that you,
uh,
may have missed during the week.
Tuesday is dead lifting and then any exercise that will help bring up the
deadlift.
It could be an ab movement,
it could be a movement for the glutes,
it could be movements for the hamstrings.
Whatever you feel is going to bring up your deadlift,
even grip work.
Thursday is all bench pressing.
And then it's going to be the main movement.
It's going to be some form of a bench press.
And then all the movements after that are all things that are going to help
improve the bench press.
So that could,
that could be a wide range of things.
You got some tricep movements and he sorta tricep extension any further pressing
would help even overhead pressing and help the actual bench press itself.
And then obviously thickening of the back and making your back bigger and making
your back stronger can help a lot as well because your back is what we're lying
on and we lie on the bench,
the shelf,
it's the stabilizer to everything and uh,
and then squat.
And then Saturday is our squat day.
Um,
and then again all the assistants exercises to everything.
After that,
it's going to be all,
all movements that are going to help increase the strength of the squat.
And again,
Sunday is kind of anything that you missed where the week or anything you want
to Polish up.
Maybe you have a lagging muscle group,
maybe you conditioning sucks.
So you might go outside,
push the prowler,
push a sled or something like that.
V The vomit.
Rocket Prowler.
So let's,
let's keep moving here.
Other,
these bench presses are a lot wider and a lot thicker.
Everything in this gym is,
is specialized field is barbell.
Couldn't fill that bar.
Cool.
Very rough.
It's,
it's like a cheese grater.
Grater.
Yeah.
What's,
I mean what type of a test of these myths?
The wife,
he loves that you're,
you're gentle caressing hands.
Gross.
What's,
uh,
what type of bench is this?
What does the manufacturer,
yeah,
this,
this uh,
particular bench came from uh,
elite fts.com and they make a wider,
uh,
bench so that way your shoulders aren't off the bench.
And then also the pad is very thick so you can really sink into it and drive
into it.
A lot of times a bench press becomes very unsafe when you're,
if you press off of a board rather than like a nice thick pad because your,
your Scapula is moving and sliding and gliding around in the shoulder socket as
you're pressing and you're going to need a nice soft pad two to help be able to
pick up the phone.
And these are four bands.
Yep.
That's the hook.
Some bands in there.
You take the band and you put it up here and you're,
you're good to go on that.
What is this for?
What is,
what does this hold?
Oh,
that's for a,
that's a safety safety support,
which I got it.
You see how much we care about that?
We don't have it in there.
So that would be the equivalent of like a power rack pole that would prevent it
from dropping under the chest.
Correct.
Got It.
Yeah.
The bench down at the end has one you can see.
Oh,
right,
right.
I got it.
So if you get stuck in your weakest range of motion,
you can pop it up onto this.
Yeah,
you can just drop it right there and they're good to go hot it.
Got It.
What is this?
Oh,
uh,
you shouldn't ask the pitch shark.
Okay.
There's a lesson,
a Tim Ferriss.
He's going to learn.
Oh boy.
Don't ask questions unless you want to be put to work.
So we're going to move some of this stuff out of the way.
Okay.
And we're going to make Tim Ferriss squat.
All right.
Fuck it.
And do all this even when we don't even care how much weight's on there.
Yeah,
that's,
that's well,
I do care.
I don't know way.
There's,
there's some of that on there.
Hold on.
Keep it later.
Too much.
A little too much.
We don't want to blog his spine or his kneecap.
No,
that'd be,
that'd be terrible.
This one fleet would probably be good.
All right,
so just so we're clear,
I have no idea what this machine is.
This is a belt squat.
He's on like a pair of undies.
Giant pair of undies.
Step into it.
There you go.
The belt goes in the back there.
It's changed those in the front.
You're going to hook the hook onto here and my standing stand on there
when you sit here on,
on the furthest most portion here.
Yeah.
Wherever you feel like putting it.
When you stand up it's going to release from here and I'll go ahead and do some
squats.
Uh,
the advantage of this exercise is the weight's not on your back.
So upper body mobility and you can also move in and use this.
You can hang on there.
And that's actually the way I use it.
Quite odd is this.
Oh that's the catch.
Yeah.
This is to to finish.
Yup.
Um,
but there's a couple advantages going on here.
This is actually pulling you down towards the ground and for some people that
struggle with getting depth in the squat,
this piece of equipment can help solve a lot of problems because it's literally
pulling you down towards the ground.
Whereas a regular squat,
it's only kind of pushing you down towards,
you can see it being very helpful for working on mobility in the ankles to in a
way mobility in the ankles.
It's going to build up a lot of strength around the kneecap,
which is what we need.
Hmm.
Let's try a couple of reps in [inaudible] five and around.
This can feel your quads.
This thing is absolutely devastating.
If tit hat Tim had longer time to spend here,
I just,
I would chain him to the rack and I just make him stay here all day.
All right.
That's good.
There we go.
Good.
There you go.
You're out of there.
It's a cool device.
Now his legs will be shaking the rest of the world.
Thank God I'm wearing pants or he'd see my legs trembling
Bambi out on the ice.
I just an old school lat pull down.
This actually a hunk of dinosaur equipment has been with super training gym from
the very beginning,
so it's something that I'll,
I'll probably always have.
So this,
I think it was what you're talking about earlier.
Oh,
hold on.
You get that one.
I'll get this one and then we'll jabs you run from the other side of that.
This is the,
this is the American glide here.
Just portion of the program,
right?
You go down that way and I'll run and we'll meet in the middle.
Ready?
I think I'm going to fail on the body weight punching above my weight class.
Yeah.
So this guy here is,
um,
this is a bamboo bar.
Uh,
basically it's made out of like a,
almost like a fiberglass type material band.
bill.com.
Okay.
EMACS,
emacs.
When we put this on the,
on the bench press and we booked some kettle bells to it,
it causes a very chaotic style of bench pressing.
The bar bends a lot.
So you'd have bands that are then attached to the Kettlebell.
We should hook it up.
Let's look it up.
That's not good.
It all right.
Here we go.
So we're going to take a band.
Yup.
And we're going to loop it through I kettlebell somewhere.
Yep.
Going to go like this.
Here we've got the band like Yay.
Okay.
And now we're just going to put it through a kettle bell.
Let's grab something juicy.
Huh?
Uh,
since he said I'm going to demonstrate.
Yup.
I'll go something light.
Now this will still be hard.
So you've got gotta.
Okay.
So
I'll kind of demo it one more time real quick so you can kind of see how it's
done.
And don't load that on there yet because the thing has no weight to it.
Yes,
I can have,
here's the band she traditional style exercise band on a folder and half Babu.
And then we're going to take this guy and we're going to put it right there.
Here
think I'm doing this right.
Yep.
And then need to put it on at the same time like this so you don't kill each
other.
Yep.
Okay.
Hold on a sec.
Right here.
Yup.
Right there.
And so you can see,
uh,
you know,
you can see this already kind of hanging through here right now.
I loaded this thing up before with about 300 pounds or 50 pounds or so,
and it really starts to band and really starts to get pretty crazy.
Do a little bit of this.
They should all die.
This,
uh,
you absolutely,
positively,
always need a spotter for,
I don't,
don't think I'm going to be a much healthier,
but yeah.
Okay.
One,
two,
three up.
There we go.
All.
I got it so you can see the instability already.
With a newer lifter,
there'll be really shaking and trembling all over the place,
but you can see how the harder that you press it,
the more resistance that wants to give you a really starts to go all over it
because they start,
there's more agitation of the kettlebells.
Yup.
And you really want to try to squeeze the kettle bell.
You want to try to have your legs stay tight,
like if your legs are loose,
then everything else gets loosey Goosey and you start to shake a lot.
Do you want everything to be locked in?
Everything can be tight.
We'll find a good pressing motion that you can handle and you try to stay in
that groove.
We do this exercise,
we'll do sets of 20 reps or so,
sometimes 30 reps depending on a workout.
This is something I do pretty much on a weekly basis.
I'll do this every,
every Sunday.
Every Thursday is my heavy lifting,
and then every Sunday is my lighter lifting where I'll do stuff like this.
Cool.
I'll try it.
I think I'll continue the tour.
All right.
Uh,
let's,
let's take a look at some of the,
the other equipment here.
So this I think will be recognizable folks.
45 degree back.
Right now,
this looks a lot wider than the platforms.
I would see it in a normal commercial gym.
Why is that?
So that you can do wider stance?
Yeah,
exactly.
You just go out wider and you can target different areas of your butt and your
hamstrings.
Um,
we in here a lot of times with power lifting,
squat is done with a wider than shoulder width stance.
And so we're trying to get wider than shoulder width stance on ab movements,
on lower back movements,
on any other movement that we can find.
What does,
so how would you squat?
What does the technique look like?
A generally for a competition lifts.
So before there was any power thing,
gear before there's any suits or anything like that,
lifters started kind of recognizing,
well,
if I go out wide,
if you go out wide with me here,
we're going to squat together,
Tim Ferris.
Alright.
And if you point your toes straight ahead and you begin to swat down,
you'll kind of feel your hips almost lock up right away.
And the wider that you go in the street are ahead that you go,
the more locked up you are.
So lifters from years ago recognize this and almost created so much internal
pressure or they needed 400 pounds,
500 pounds from them,
they'll even break parallel.
So that's a little excessive going that wide and it may not be manageable.
So when we bring the stance in a little bit,
but we're still getting some of that tension just outside of shoulder width,
just outside shoulder width.
And we're also going to point the toes out at least a little bit because we want
the hips to have at least some freedom now that a barbell on my back without a
warmup,
it's hard for me to really move the way I should,
but all I'm trying to do,
I'm trying to bring my upper body through my lower body.
I don't need to push back like this.
I don't need to lean forward like this.
All I needed to have happened is my hips to move a lot.
My hips need to move downward.
Continue in one continuous motion for the entire time.
So my feet,
you want to get your feet connected to the ground.
You want to be grounded firmly into the ground.
These shoes are not ideal for this cause.
You can see I'm rolling out.
Where do you want to flatter shoe,
but as I go to descend,
I'm opening up through the groin and shoving the knees forward and starting to
kind of push my head and shoulders back a little bit and I'll come back up for
me in warmups.
I'll stay in this range here.
I'm not concerned about setting some sort of world records for squat depth.
I worry about that as I warm up as I handle more weight.
But the squatch be very efficient.
All you're trying to do,
keep your stomach tight and have your hips move in one continuous motion
downward,
but you don't want to get here and go like this,
right?
Because then your hips in getting lower.
It's all one continuous motion we're trying to get through here.
Got It.
And you study that really struggle.
I can show you a quick tip.
This just works as a counterbalance.
He just saw where my range of motion was limited to the second ago.
So I'm here and I'm kind of getting stuck here.
Yep.
All right.
Take this guy here.
This is our counterbalance.
That's our kettle bell and we're going to go here and as we get here,
we can squat down lower because we have a counterbalance weight,
right?
That will allow us to get a little lower.
So that'll act as a stretch and he can do that.
You don't need a Kettlebell for it can use a 25 pound plate.
Yeah,
same 10 pound plate.
A lot of people noticed that I went to Albert Squat kettlebells.
Exactly.
Doing a pistols and things like that.
Also very helpful to have the kind of balance.
Uh,
what about these right here?
These are our items that uh,
you know,
aside from being useful for resting your coffee on this,
what is this?
This guy hears the reverse hyper extension machine.
It's a way to train your lower back without loading it up with a barbell.
Um,
it's a great for restoration help to pump blood into lower back.
and it's also going to gently stretch the spine with each motion that you and a,
so you're,
I'm not going to necessarily do this,
but the basic idea is you getting up like so looping in and then lifting the
weight like sets,
right.
And you can see how much activation he's getting off his bike.
He's really flexing hard.
It's going to get your glutes,
your hamstrings and your lower back.
And like I said,
it's going to gently stretch your spine for those of you as lower back injuries.
This is a great piece.
And uh,
it was this reasonably,
was it created or just popularized by,
by Louie Louie Simmons is the patent holder of the [inaudible] where we covered
this in the podcast we did together where routine,
it's an 800 pound bench press.
Thousand pounds squad.
Yeah.
Everyday occurrence.
And they,
they,
and they don't have a history of lower back issues in our gym.
And that's a testament to this product here.
Very cool.
Sell solar as a Ghd glute ham developer.
Uh,
but you can also do sit ups off of it.
You can do,
uh,
a basically like a hamstring curl off,
similar to a hyper extension,
but the plane of your legs is level is that there is,
yeah.
Now,
just pro tip for people who are thinking about doing an ab work on these.
Uh,
so you may have or may not have heard the term of Rhabdo rubbed on my license.
So if you suddenly decide as a weekend warrior,
I've never done crossfit before,
let me do a bunch of Ab hyper extension exercises on this.
You may end up in the hospital,
uh,
because your kidneys might not like the amount of muscular damage you do.
So take it slow folks.
Take it slow.
Yeah,
moving too fast,
moving too fast on any of the movements that are going to actually kind of
stretch you,
uh,
is,
is a dangerous proposition.
Take your time with the exercises that,
anything that's new that you ever try,
take your time with it.
Even the amount of weight that you're moving,
amount of weight you're lifting.
Really tried to take your time with it.
You don't want to get hurt and this is a weighted sled.
Yeah,
just a simple sled with a rope on it.
You can pick up the straps here and you can just take her for a stroll.
You just take it for a walk.
You can walk backwards with it.
If you walk,
I'll just walk with it a little bit just to show you,
you walk backwards with it,
it's going to work.
Your quads
walked backwards in your work,
your quads.
He walked forward with it and it's going to work.
Your hamstrings and your button.
You can kind of going here,
very simple piece of equipment works your calves where it's your ankles works,
works your whole posterior chain.
You can also do rowing motions with it.
You can do explosive rowing motions with it too,
which is kind of Nice.
You can kind of roll like this,
work your upper back where you can kind of go
whatever way,
whatever way you want.
You can turn the other way and bench press with it as well.
Um,
this is one of my favorite pieces of equipment.
I liked to do,
I used to very often but not as much anymore should get my big butt back out
here to do more of this.
But uh,
you should just set my clock for about a half an hour and I'd walk forward and
backwards with it and then I would throw it and then I would push it and I would
just do it until the 30 minutes was up.
That's a decent period of time.
That's like ultra endurance or power lifters keep moving him.
Nothing.
If you had to choose between the weight sled or the Prowler,
which would you choose a wise and for people who are curious,
the prowler,
if you could imagine a couple of cars coming up to about here and you hold onto
it and push it.
This guy here is a prowler right here,
triangular piece.
So a couple of different variations of it,
but you can hold on to this and push it around.
You're actually physically kind of pushing it with your hands.
If you were,
if you had to choose one or the other,
which would you choose?
And I like the sled a little bit better because a,
the sled is usually much,
much cheaper.
Um,
if you want to be real cheap about it.
And my ability to even get somebody locally to make that for a very inexpensive
price.
Um,
but I liked the,
the ability to do so many different things off.
Whereas with the prowler you're really just pushing it and that's Kinda all you
can do this.
You can push it,
you can bench with it,
you can roll with it and walk forward or backwards with it.
Very cool.
All right.
Let's see what else we have said.
This is another one.
This is called the back of the pack.
It's a basically a good morning machine.
This pad right here,
it goes on your lower,
it goes on your upper back,
got up near your neck and you,
you get in there and you kind of just do this motion here.
Um,
the difference between a weak person and a strong person is the lower back.
The stronger your lower back is a stronger that you become.
Let me ask a silly question.
What is the value of the good morning?
If you're already doing dead lifts and squats,
it's just a different range of motion.
Just a different option,
but you're 100% correct.
You could possibly be overdoing it and uh,
and maybe uh,
two to a detriment of,
of doing too much lower backwards if you're already squatting and dead lifting
him.
Where are they?
Good morning comes in really handy is to replace something like the dead lift
for a few weeks or to do a little bit of assistance work on occasion again in a
little bit more reps,
a little bit more work with some lighter weights is also going to kind of
stretch you differently because the Barbie on your backs and it puts you down
where a lot differently than just holding the weights while you're effectively,
I mean obviously technically there are a bunch of details that are important to
pay attention to for safety reasons,
but you're effectively doing what you said not to do in the squat,
right?
Right.
You're doing it on purpose with control and technical objective.
We'll also to,
uh,
the other great thing about a good morning,
if there is anything great about it and they hurt really bad,
they're brutal.
But the one thing that is great about it is it does get the weights out of your
hands.
Yeah.
We have so much weight in our hands all the time that we end up with tons of
elbow issues,
tons of a tendonitis and problems through the forearms and elbows.
So anytime you have an opportunity to not hold something right,
it's a good opportunity to take.
So that's,
that's actually a good segue over to this stuff over here.
So now what is this machine called?
We will,
you want to try to get too much in the way,
but what does this guy,
this guy right here is called a monolift.
I'll actually just demonstrate it for you with the second,
I can just hop underneath year.
So the model lift is kind of great because all he has to do is stand up with the
weight.
He doesn't have to really even walk anywhere.
So as he stands up,
we're going to release it right from here and he can do a squat right there.
He probably hasn't really used the model of the aspect of it.
You probably just using it as a squat rack and put it back in the rack again.
And so that's why he moved his feet around.
But as we become used to the model lift a little bit more,
you can get yourself wedged in there just right.
And when you unrack the weights,
there's no more walking with it.
Right.
Is this,
is this,
this looks like a bit like a safety squat bar,
but what,
what is this?
Because it also has,
that is a safety squad and safety squat bar.
Yeah.
The,
uh,
so the padding through here will allow to lift her to get getting completely
different center of gravity.
Then they would have,
if they were trying to hold a barbell on their back.
Um,
you're also taking a lot of tension,
hey,
taken a lot of tension and stress off because you're listening.
They hear Bonk with the head.
Yeah.
Uh,
as opposed to correct.
And so we've had lifters in here who have torn their tricep.
We've had lifters in here who have torn their biceps before and they could still
lift with this piece of equipment that I had to worry about getting their arm
and some weird,
precarious position to be able to do a swab.
And,
uh,
this right here is this,
that's the devil.
Oh,
because the depth low bar.
And is this for beds or is this for chains?
What does this for?
Yes,
it's for all of the above.
All the above.
You can put bands on there.
Um,
there's chains,
right?
Exactly.
You put whatever,
whatever you need in there.
This piece of equipment is really nice for a good mornings.
And we were talking about the good morning earlier.
We tried to do a good morning with a straight bar.
The bar has tendency to want to roll up your back with a bar that's bent or
Cambridge,
like this one is already,
the bar will stay where,
where you want it to stay and it's easier to actually do a true good morning.
An a true good morning is when you take your shoulders and try to get them out
past your toes what you're trying to do.
So with the straight bar,
it's very hard to really be wedged in there.
The right way to do the good morning,
the right way.
And he got some key low plates there and those are basically just for
competition.
So because we compete,
we're competitive power lifters.
That's a one way for us to compete and utilize the stuff that we actually use in
the event itself.
If we only train with bumper plates and we only trained with a regular metal,
or you can see how thick this plate is here,
this bumper plate,
I think that is compared to that.
Right,
right.
A much,
much different feel.
That's 55 pounds as opposed to this being 45 pounds a train is,
you'll compete them.
Right.
You want to get used to those pieces of equipment.
So there's no surprises when you go into a power through me.
See,
you have a hex or a trap bar so you can step inside this and do all sorts of
stuff.
Yep.
What about this guy that's Cambrin Bar?
What would you use this for?
Mainly for squats and good morning.
Uh,
sometimes people have used it.
Even for the old school.
Zirtual squat we put into the cooks your elbows.
Very brutal.
And what would the benefit of this be over the Duffalo Bar?
In what cases would this be there?
Not too much different from each other.
Got It.
Uh,
you probably wouldn't need to have both pieces.
You probably pick one over the other bottle of stuff.
We'll leave that there.
Well actually this is a,
this is smelling salt was smelling salts.
So,
um,
so you shake it up and it's got like some different stuff in it.
But like this one,
well who knows?
It's just a white look at where are we?
Let just get to have a white bottle with nothing on it.
There's no way,
but there's no expiration date on it and an underpass.
Yeah,
exactly.
Some of the guys will make their own combinations and stuff in here and
sometimes you can even smell it through the bottle and then you know,
you're really screwed when you open it up.
But this one's been sitting there for a while,
so I don't think it's that bad.
Yeah,
it's not that bad.
Normally if you even get close to it,
you just get hit like a ton of bricks that basically,
it's just a wake the hell up for your set that you're doing.
It's almost like someone just came up and just smacked you in your face,
which some power lifters also have people do.